you have to play this video all right
here we go I got a long last name
European name steinhauser there's been
some confusion over your last name and
the pronunciation and I'm just wondering
to correct the record what is it oh it's
ridiculous these stupid things listen
the way to pronounce my last name
winner I'm sorry man I don't know
who picking on a guy that has
autism stop it please leave him alone
buy you're you're a pro at this is that
clip going viral tonight oh yo yo guys
guys guys Nikki Haley is within 16 votes
of beating Ronda
Sanz wow she's going to Ron's going to
finish in in in a third place and look
if he was a smart guy he drops out
tomorrow morning endorses president
Trump tucks his tail between his legs
goes back to Tallahassee but I don't
think that's you're right man I mean
here's a question so Ron's gone hard in
the pain against Trump right like I
haven't missed this on the campaign
Trail I can't pay attention to
everything everyone says but Ron's gone
real hard he's ran directly at Trump MH
how do you take that back right how do
you then endorse the guy I think it's
expected in politics I mean Maybe not
maybe not because trashing your
opponent's different than explaining why
you're the best and also we've seen
people get Trashed by Trump and then
endorse him and it's not exactly the
same but people have very clearly
humiliated them lying Ted Cruz yeah he
he knocked Ted Cruz's wife too like
he he called Ted Cruz lying Ted and then
after the fight was over it changed to
lion like and then it was like it was
honorable to be clear Ted Cruz did not
endorse president Trump for this cycle
so Ted still has n Haley is within two
votes of beating Ronda I think the best
thing Ron can do is support the party
and not support necessarily I mean he
could go support Trump but I mean you
gota you got a party Unity at some point
and um maybe they'll make amends you
know I don't think they they dislike
each other personally is it still 1% of
the vote in 1% of votes are in I mean
hey it's early it's I think we're going
to start getting big chunks and it's
going to jump up faster and faster as
the night we're getting closer to 8:00
uh I do think it's funny they already
called it for Trump though weird like
instantly they call yeah with less than
1% of the vote in they're like ah he won
you know what's funny is because they're
saying that it's been called by the AP
before most were in which means it was
based on polls it's probably just some
dude at the AP being like guys there's
no way anyone else is winning just say
Trump won I want to go home let's just
get out of here these caucus things
people just go and then they vote but
like anyone can go and vote you to be
registered so you can are they paying
people to go do it like is the santis 99
million partly like we're going to make
sure that you have got a car to the
caucus that you can get there early they
imported the entire cabinet and
government agency staffers of the State
of Florida to go door Todo in you know
this frigid temperature uh and beg
people to go caucus for run and uh you
know it obviously didn't work out too
well for them a lot of out of stator
showing up at somebody's door in Iowa
like the Iowans you know don't really
appreciate that a whole lot um but this
is that was theery evacuation plan SP a
lot of time with VI I've talked to him
many time multiple times four or five
times and uh I've been insulated in his
campaign in the last week I thought
there was a shot that maybe he would
come up on top this to me is like I'm
done with this Republican political
debacle Trump's got it this is it trp
got it Trump's the nominee it that that
that I look Trump has gone from 70 at
less than 1% with the race called for
him he's now at
57.7% even if Ron Nikki and vies were
all added up they're still not beating
Donald Trump he's too famous he's so
famous what about can we see where Cruz
is at I'm actually curious has he gotten
is no there's zero for Christy sorry not
Cruz Christie has four what if like
Chris chrisy flies at those four people
and like has dinner with him he's like
thank you so much for thinking of
me I nice thing did the right thing we
had a request in because we call him
chrisp Krispy uh on my show and we had a
request in to go to a Crispy Cream
that's right down the uh street from my
studio and to Nikki Haley's beating
Ronda San how
sad bird brain will be much easier to
destroy than Ron by the way we haven't
even started on well look Nikki
Democrats the the the rumor is and I
would warn everyone don't fall for this
trap should it be like Rhino Republicans
or you know whatever establishment
shills but the argument right now is
that Democrats are crossing party lines
to vote for Nikki if it goes to a
general election they're not going to
vote for Nikki no so she she might get
higher percentages in the primary
process she's not going to get in the
general that sounds like really really
dirty yeah that you could you go and you
you register as a republican youve
you've caucus for the wrong person and
then you can switch back to Democrat
afterwards come on that's insane yeah
that's so stupid Cheney's political
career right that can't be allowed going
forward I mean you you register you
register what can you do about it I
don't know year so it's 2023 you're like
I don't want Trump to win register as a
republican a year later you go in
us for someone else and then you in the
general can vote forever you want or you
switch parties after the caucus is over
and that's because a republican can vote
for a democrat in the no because you can
register for whatever party you want you
can change party affiliation you're free
to do so it's free speech it's free
association or whatever Tim do you think
that all the Twitter Bots for Ron were
able to vote in the Iowa caucus no yeah
I do think I I think Ron his campaign I
don't I I don't I will say this I don't
know for sure I'm not accusing him of
doing anything but I will say does it
does seem most people would agree that a
lot of the pro descendant accounts
online are Bots yeah I don't know if
they're say with the campaign or not but
you see they'll have some generic name
with a gator in the name they'll have
some kind of cartoon character as the
profile picture and they all respond in
the exact same ways and I'm just like it
is not organic at least the Trump people
say weird things or insult you in
different ways like who no I'm just
talking like like you Maga guy 519 or
whatever will
write yeah you're right I guess I do
that the sis campaign walked right into
so much of this I mean that's wild it
was it was just like I I I'm you know
maybe it's a little crass or whatever
but that photo was posted of Des Sis's
people and Christina Pasha had her knees
made red in you know Photoshop or
whatever I didn't get that what did that
mean after that it was like that was the
moment where I noticed she went from
dming with people I knew we were talking
with her about having her or attendant
come on the show after that photo came
out it was like just the Gates of Hell
had been Unleashed and I think that
broke her yeah I think it broke it
appeared to me that she was using
campaign resources to settle personal
scores and she had a lot of the campaign
assets and and folks just went to battle
for her instead of actually doing
something that was helpful to the
candidate yo this is crazy that n
pulling ahead yeah that's what it looks
like unfortunately wow she's she's up 23
Point votes so far on Ona santis so if
Ron drops at 10% that' be $10 million
per percentage Point that's not good wow
wow that's so much money uh who spent
more Nikki or Ron Ron in Iowa Ron Ron
put his all of the eggs in in Iowa he
had his entire ground game here he
bragged about how great their operation
was here um never backed down his super
pack had their bus here basically the
entire campaign they pulled out of New
Hampshire uh many months ago and his
whole campaign was re on Iowa and that's
why he sought the endorsements of Steve
de and Bob Vander plats and these people
who were once considered Iowan King
maker King makers and I don't think any
campaign is going to be seeking their
endorsements uh next go around yo it's
it's it's kind of wild to have been
someone look year and almost two years
ago I'm hanging out with the daily wire
crew a story I've told a million times
and we're talking about why we think
Ronda santis is the guy it's well before
Trump was back in the race a lot of
things changed since then and we're like
gr's young he's got energy he's got
great policy he's really working for
Florida everyone's really excited by him
and then as time went on we got a little
more disenfranchised it got to the point
where I was like yeah I'm kind of 5050 I
think Trump's back his speech was pretty
good I like Ronda santz we'll see what
happens I just got a text from Wesley
Hunt's uh Chief of Staff a Ronda santis
supporter just charged Wesley while he
was a trump serate at caucus location
video coming soon whoa so these folks
aren't handling the loss well well this
is what I W okay they'll never back down
that's right oh my God here's what I
want to say about like there was a
period where Ronda FIS thank you thank
you I'm a father of three my dad jokes I
really appreciate any fathers in the
audience I really appreciate the
appreciation of the dad joke thank you
Ron was winning in the prediction
markets handily like two to one against
Trump over time Ron started doing true
yeah he start he start he started doing
worse and worse so someone like me I
start making apt points about how his
campaign is being run his la punch was
bad he lacked Charisma and even after
all that I I like the guy's got good
policies got to turn this around and
what did they respond with attacking
anyone who would dare criticize his
failing campaign now we're at the point
where we're like this guy has totally
failed but there are a lot of
personalities who attached them you know
tied their their hitch to the the the
disis wagon and no matter how bad things
got they kept saying no he's the best no
I refuse to back down a very bad dag Bob
bag what are they going to do well are
they going to try and come back and be
like Maga please take me back into your
warm bosom I'm sorry I supported this
guy who whose campaign was miserable
yeah no or or they do a Lincoln project
type group and uh you know I don't
really want some of those folks on our
side we've they've actually become a
detriment of Ron I don't want I mean I
don't really want a lot of his people
being advocates for us out there like
normal normal people look at some of
these people like they think they're
weird so uh I hope they stay far away
from Trump World uh moving forward I
would love to make it less about who and
more about what we do moving forward as
a union like this making the America
great again like we do it constantly
we've made this country great uh let's
do it again let's let's let's
reinvigorate the country with new
technology and give the 21st century a
run for its money I don't to be honest I
don't even care who the president is if
they're willing to do that well I think
I think this is a a great message and I
think some of these numbers are going to
hold pretty pretty closely here and
president Trump I believe we'll get over
50% and that is a mandate the voters
want president Trump he's going to go on
to win New Hampshire go on to win South
Carolina this primary should and we
should we should come together uh and
and focus our fight on Joe Biden this
this is interesting uh Johnson County
Nikki Haley has the lead if I may I'm
from Johnson County this this is where
the University of Iowa is this is the
large one of the the largest centralized
liberal populations in Iowa and this is
what the polling showed that Joe Biden
voters support Nikki Haley and these are
Democrats voting in the Republicans this
is liberal land right there this is the
college town like communist Marxist
professors Johnson County that's story
count that is Nikki Haley is winning in
Story County also a college County and V
is in second that's am that's the
University of uh that's Iowa State why
do you think it is that the Democrats uh
generally are supporting Nikki Haley
same policiy as Joe bid it's Hillary
Clinton yeah right he a warhog 2.0 it's
but she's not even like Joe Biden with a
wig on but it's not even a joke to be
like haha she's like Hillary it's like
no she's literally got the same policies
it's crazy Joe Biden simar you know
Nikki Haley gets offended if you call
illegal aliens criminals yeah you know
she says climate change is a national
security threat Nikki Haley is straight
up on video multiple times saying that
Hillary Clinton's her hero right and she
worked with Trump she was his ambassador
to the UN that's what it was what she
was appointed by Trump yeah and then she
raised her hand one time and then was
she okay was she cool then was she the
same it's kind of a role I
think we should defund the UN I think we
should be out of the UN so you just put
somebody there that wants the title but
they don't really do a whole lot thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net